pull up the crime because somebody asked
the question about
top crime in America and says it's
liberal is it conservative okay let's
find out these cities most violent
cities in America go up go up go up go
up go up go up to the right to the
ranking okay St Louis is it the liberal
or conservative any major city any major
city yeah is going to be blue any major
city got it so the crime in all major
cities ran by liberals is the highest
crime in America so when people say when
hokel says it's not this it's not that
no problem here's what your policies are
doing it's so bad that Nancy Pelosi's
husband was broken into his house and
yesterday the I think it's the D.A that
was talking about is saying when the man
broke into his house he was in his
underwear and he got up and went to the
other place to make the phone call and
so but these are the policies of San
Francisco and the guy that broke into
San Francisco he's a BLM guy that broke
into the place of San Francisco
according to people that knew this guy
said this isn't this is a BLM Guy this
is a guy that supported BLM this is a
guy that support a lot of that stuff but
broke in but wait a second guy in the
neighborhood they would say yeah using
drugs openly yeah but I thought he was
more of a q Anon Maga guy from what I've
heard he had a BLM flag on his he lived
in a bus he had a BLM flag an lgbtq flag
a bus parked in the front yard of a
deterioration it's like a hippie commune
uh took uh but that was the media story
that you're citing the media story
initially was oh this is a republican q
and on guy and then they dug and we're
like uh not exactly and he wound up
being this hippie commune drug user guy
a troubled guy trouble guy mental health
issues but but more than anything the
the stories that I've heard again we're
gonna go with we can't trust what the
media is saying left right we're just
hearing stories the story that I'm
hearing putting out there especially on
the right is like this was his gay lover
entanglement issue male process which is
the truth I'm not on that well people
are pushing that as my point you know
what rational neighbors were saying this
is a troubled guy that's using drugs to
get this bus parked over in the law and
they got all these signs up he's you
know yelling at the moon and he's just a
really troubled guy I think that has
been fully established the guy with
mental health issues somehow ended up
inside Paul Pelosi's house and bunked
him with a hammer right so looking for
Nancy though well he wasn't coming there
who knows how do you know that though
that's the part
this is the part again the first thing
they did the first thing they did is
blame who Republicans the first thing
they did is blame Republicans the first
thing they did
blame all the war blame queuing on he's
part the first thing and then a day
later oh he's he's gay he's a prostate
he's he's a new he's a PLM he's a LGBT
oh well no no let's let's move on with
the story okay so here's what's going on
over here in Chicago so so not Jesse's
that's the that's the part where they
the reason why a New York could almost
lose governorship is because people are
saying I am not dumb you know the The
Joe Rogan said something yesterday he
says the the red uh the what did he call
it it's gonna be like The Shining when
the elevator opens you know the the way
people are going to be voting Grant he
says like when the elevator opens from
shining he says it's gonna be insane
what's gonna happen on that side and
obviously we're gonna find that next
week how much of this is just gibberish
and how much of this is credibility or
not you know people aren't dumb and I
think one of the things I was looking at
is you step back from the election
season and you look what happened to the
D.A Adam the D.A of San Francisco right
those people had a had a referendum
against the D.A in San Francisco why was
that they weren't in the middle of
election season with million dollar ads
and billboards and TV and radio that you
can't avoid right they were I see
needles I see human feces I see homeless
encampments I see my city deteriorating
I see somebody mugs me and they're back
out on the street two weeks later on the
same Corner waiting to mug me again time
out I'm done with it and to your point
Pat the San Francisco voters were not
dumb did they stop being liberal stop
having certain views no they didn't but
they looked around and they said you as
my D.A are not keeping my city with I
want the liberal values to be here but
it's got to be safe at a basic level and
I see this and I'm not done so guess
what you're done and that's what they
did you probably got the story somewhere
on the liberal uh the recall let's not
forget that they invalidated half a
million votes
um and they cheated these people people
out of recalling uh gascon uh no I'm
just looking at the D.A and I'm looking
at things that they really saw in San
Francisco you know what people really
saw they tried and then uh they
invalidated half a million signatures
out of the 715 000. so during the
presidential election or the
gubernatorial election for Gavin Newsom
everybody can vote everybody in their
freaking mother can vote and they're not
going to recall a single ballot I'm not
talking Governor I was just talking to
San Francisco D.A but that's what I'm
saying when they're trying to do a
recall and they're trying to pull George
gascon out they're going to recall half
a million ballots like it just shows how
everything's Twisted that's the Lida you
go to San Francisco D.A and that guy got
tossed out on his head when you're what
you're talking about though Tom when you
say liberal values oftentimes in these
places like the New York cities the San
Francisco's what they want upheld is
like the the social values like for
example Giuliani got elected Giuliani
was pro-choice it would be impossible
impossible for a pro-life candidate to
win in New York
um I don't know about what where Lee
zeldon stands on the pro-life issue or
how outspoken he is about that but
oftentimes they're talking about like
where do you stand on abortion where do
you stand on this but they prioritize
these liberal voters do prioritize
Safety and Security they may back the
defund the police movement with a
sticker in their window but they don't
want to be unsafe they want to know that
when they pick up the phone and they
call for the police that the police show
up and they want to know that they get
there in time so this perception is oh
liberals don't care about safety no
liberals don't care liberals want the
slogan they want to be in the cool Club
defund the police BLM put the flags up
all that stuff but they don't want that
lack of safety to impact their
neighborhood or their family once they
does once it actually lands in their
backyard they will absolutely Embrace
somebody who prioritizes their security
as long as that person also bows to some
key issues has to be you know
pro-abortion has to be you know there's
certain boxes that need to be checked so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]